oh hi you might be thinking that there
aren't that many video games coming out
for the rest of the year and that in
fact there's really not much left to the
rest of the year and you are right on
both counts however there are still a
couple things you're going to want to
keep on your radar as we close out the
glorious year of 2012 wired editors
agree that our game of the year for 2012
is the walking dead an episodic
adventure game series by Telltale Games
now this was downloadable on the xbox
playstation 3 and pc but if you just
hate downloading things we have really
good news for you The Walking Dead is
now available on disk for 360 and
playstation 3 pay once get the entire
series and boy you have got to play the
walking dead if you haven't already so
if you want to buy it in stores you can
now get the walking dead as of December
11 and either a normal edition or this
handsome phenomenal amazing and quite
expensive limited edition perfect for
fans of the comic book or the television
show and quite frankly even if you don't
like zombies this game is so great
you've got to play it anyway Mega Man
fans may be a little bit sad that after
the creator of the series left Capcom a
little while ago Capcom went ahead and
cancelled every Mega Man game in its
entire schedule okay maybe you're more
pissed off than sad but Capcom doesn't
want you to burn down its office so I'm
December 17th it is releasing a free fan
made game that looks really cool it's
called street fighter vs Mega Man you
play as Megaman but instead of fighting
robot bosses you fight the characters
from Street Fighter knowing how to play
megaman is important and apparently
knowing how to fight those Street
Fighter characters in their own martial
arts game will extend into this bizarre
8-bit themed crossover world Capcom is
releasing this game through its website
Capcom calm for free starting December
17 so Mega Man fans it's not entirely
going to be a horrible for
miss for you just mostly but if you
aren't iPhone gamer then street fighter
vs Megaman may not be the most impactful
crossover the most astonishing collision
of worlds that will happen to you this
year maybe this is a sign of the end
times but two of the biggest stars on
iOS are finally meeting in a crossover
game for the ages yes swampy the
alligator and Perry the Platypus from
Phineas and Ferb are finally getting
together in where's my holiday taking
the elements of where's my water and
where's my Perry two of the biggest hits
on the iPhone and merging them all into
one water-based brain scratcher of a
puzzle game where's my holiday will be
available on December twentieth thanks
for joining us all this year on game
life look forward to our next episode
for some of the best games besides the
walking dead but also including the
walking dead that we enjoyed over the
year 2012 and then our most anticipated
games for the year 2013
you